Das ist wirklich eine wissenschaftliche sensation zum ersten mal wurde in die quelle der
rätselhaften geister teilchen entdeckt woher sie stammen konnte bisher nicht
herausgefunden werden sie sind nämlich überhaupt nur sehr schwer zu finden obwohl sie massenhaft im weltall vorkommen die neutrinos sind
geister teilchen doch eine gigantische mess station in der antarktis
hat es jetzt geschafft und damit wurde ein jahrhundert rätsel der physik gelöst klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Da gestern prasselten auf whatsapp die nachrichten nur so rein eine neue wissenschaft sensation wurde
verkündet die entdeckung der quelle der neutrinos der geister teilchen nicht so unrecht
werden sie so bezeichnet ihre masse ist äußerst gering für die erkenntnis dass überhaupt eine haben bekamen das entsprechende forschungsteam
2015 den
nobelpreis für sich die geister teilchen gehen nur wirklich selten eine wechselwirkung mit der materie wie wir sie kennen ein weil sie eben nicht interagieren
rasen sie ungestört durch sein das macht es extrem schwierig herauszufinden
woher sie kommen doch das hat der ice cube in der antarktis jetzt
herausgefunden das observatorium namens ice cube das zur amerikanische amundsen scott
forschungsstation am südpol gehört ist wohl eines der spannendsten experimente
weltweit
5160 sensoren wurden dafür tief in den antarktischen
untergrund versenkt und zwar bis zu 2,5 kilometer tief zusammen bilden sie ein riesiges dreidimensionales
detektor feld echter wahnsinn und hier wird die sogenannte
tschernjakow strahlung erforscht damit ist das leuchten gemeint dass durch die kollision die extrem seltenen kollisionen von neutrinos
mit den wassermolekülen
das einst entstehen und das passiert nicht oft doch wenn es passiert dann richtig pro sekunde
prallen zwischen 60 und 100 milliarden neutrinos auf jeden quadratzentimeter der erde ein sie stammen von
gigantischen ereignissen welt halt wie den supernova explosionen oder
gammastrahlen ausbrüchen und ihre unfassbare beschleunigung kann man sich eigentlich gar nicht vorstellen in untersuchungen wurden tatsächlich neutrinos mit einer energie von
980 tera elektronenvolt
dv analysiert zum vergleich im lhc also dem large hadron collider des genfer
kernforschungszentrums cern sind protonen mit gerade mal 13 tera elektronenvolt am start und noch einen ziemlich krasse landen und ins mittlerweile
werden mit hilfe des ice cube auf sat 1 auch schon teilchen im bereich von peter elektronenvolt gemessen also mehr als
1000 tera elektronenvolt
neutrinos ich habe nie nebensatz zu allen anderen teilchen eine
unsere eigenschaft sie interagieren kaum oder selben mit materials haben wir schon gehört daraus ergibt sich aber auch dass sie nicht abgelenkt werden sie fliegen
direkt von der stromquelle
geradeaus trübsal und deshalb kann man nur bei ihnen herausfinden woher sie stammen und damit woher vorher ihre
unglaublichen energien stammen bisher
waren allerdings keine muster zu erkennen sie kamen aus allen richtungen mit schwachen und hohen energien ein muster war eben einfach nicht zu erkennen
bis zum 22
september 2017 damals entdeckte der nasa gammastrahlen die fermi eine riesige gamma strand quelle in der galaxie
txs 05 06 06 damals wurde der satellit aufgrund der messungen des ice cubes auf diese galaxie
ausgerichtet weil dort eben eine strahlenquelle vermutet wurde wie geht vom schwarzen loch im zentrum
aus das einen seiner jets direkt auf uns ausgerichtet hat es ist ein basar ein
aktives super massereiches schwarzes loch das eine extrem heiße
akkretionsscheibe um sich kreisen lässt und nach oben und unten jets ausspuckt einer trifft uns und wir können die strahlung messen
zum einen die gammastrahlung und zum anderen eben
einige wenige neutrinos und dann soll ich es wurde vorher im ice cube gefunden
zum einen dieses hoch energetische neutrino und zu anderen auch welche mit schwächerer energie den
alten daten des ice cubes aus den jahren 2013 und 14 stammten damit hat der ice cube eine wichtige erkenntnis gewonnen
solche blase sind die quelle von riesigen teilchen eruptionen und der ursprung von neutrinos jetzt wird dort weiter geforscht die
forschungsgruppen suchen jetzt neutrinos die aus bestimmten richtungen stammen und geben deren daten an
teleskope und satelliten rund um den globus weiter damit sie weitere quellen ausmachen es bleibt also spannend
bei der suche nach
strahlenquellen im weltall wenn er keine videos sagte und zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann endet mich bei whatsapp
dann umgeht er die kaputte abo boxee auf youtube und verpasst kein video denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir immer
und zwar vor allen anderen vom neuesten video täglichen garantiert
einfach dafür hier draufklicken und am besten auch mein schwesterkanal klicks um social media abonnieren
da gibt es das neueste aus der social media welt darf hier klicken aber nicht die
genau glocke vergessen wie geht es weiter mit dafür auch dort klicken neutrinos das rätsel der geister teilchen wird es jetzt gelöst
bis dann
bleib dran